dritte was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute
mal im stehen etwas andere perspektive
aber ist nicht so schlimm ist auch schön
oder es geht heute um etwas sehr
interessantes was mich aber fast ich
glaube 13.000 euro gekostet hätte ja
muss man sagen wir fangen wir damit an
vor einer woche kam mein video ich
kreiere meine eigene misery box und
verkaufe sie versteigere sie über ebay
also ich habe mein eigenes produkt
sozusagen erstellt habe da sachen rein
getan wie diese ganzen saturn boxen
mediamarkt boxen nur halt in viel besser
also da war echt sehr coole sachen drin
und die box steht auch nach wie vor und
es wäre trotz das ist auf jeden fall das
erste was da reinkommt weiter geht's mit
der nächsten sache also hier wir nehmen
einfach diese box das ist die media
markt mystery boxee von mediamarkt
mitbekommen habe es eignet sich sehr gut
als verpacktes nichts habe ich hier noch
mein letztes ipad was ich nicht verkauft
hat deswegen kommt das natürlich auch
hier ein keine ahnung wie viel die welt
sind habe ich irgendwann bekommen wir
kommen auf jeden fall auch noch ein wenn
ihr kein großes haus ab kein problem
können wir weiter verkaufen dieses ding
kostet neu nämlich soweit ich weiss 299
euro das sind jetzt vier sachen die
schon drin sind und es werden weitere
folgen von denen ihr aber nichts wisst
damit man halt so ein bisschen dieses
musical misery mäßige drin hat der sinn
davon war sondern kleine spendenaktion
und zwar wollte ich das ganze geld was
ich mit dem video verdiene
das video ist leider nicht ganz so gut
angekommen etwas schade plus das geld
was ich dann mit der box auch verdiene
wenn sich versteigert wird plus noch mal
selber ein bisschen drauf legen und das
dann halt spenden und zwar über so eine
organisation die hier sitzt aber das
ganze geld wer nach togo gegangen ich
fand das ultra nice und dachte so eng
mit der box hey ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass sie für 1200 1300 euro
weg geht so ich habe dir eingestellt und
dann habe ich das ganze erst mal
beobachtet und beobachtet und ich dachte
am anfang alter geil 400 euro ich höre
ich habe ich hab das sogar aufgenommen
ich zeige es euch jemand das müsste ich
eigentlich noch harmlose was geht video
ist gerade aufgegangen
die auktion
heute jetzt bisschen nach oben gehen
hoffe ich mache ich würde es mal so ein
bisschen festhalten ihr alex wie schnell
mystery box war man immer noch bei null
euro gerade aber wir haben jetzt 19 und
videos gerade online gegangen ich warte
jetzt mal ein bisschen und dann schauen
wir mal so leicht ein paar minuten sind
vergangen wir sind jetzt einfach schon
bei 210 euro das geld stellt 40 waren
150 und jetzt einfach 210 ziemlich große
schritte
ich bin gespannt ein so leicht
eigentlich müsste noch was möglich sein
ich habe das jetzt aufgelistet ich weiß
ich habe jetzt zeigen weil da stehen
halt die ganzen namen von den leuten
aber eigentlich schon und keine ahnung
ich habe jetzt auch schon ein paar
nachrichten bekommen hier fragt einer
ich habe eine frage zu dieser box wieso
wollen für so großen preis verkaufen
weil das eine geile box ist ja sind
geile sachen deswegen kannst du dir auch
nur für 2000 euro sofort kaufen ist doch
klar willst einfach nach 20 minuten
schon 70 gebote dann auf und dadurch
dass wir schon so viele mitbieten wird
das wahrscheinlich auch bei leuten die
mich gar nicht kennen so in die ebay
anzeigen geputscht und die schauen sich
das rauchen des wir nicht vielleicht
kennt er nicht gar nicht einfach jetzt
schon dass ich meine stadt und wir sind
schon bei 1400 euro dafür
der höchstbieter ist fakuma das vergehen
noch mehr
das heißt eigentlich ich habe ja für
2000 euro eingestellt die wird ja gleich
wäre dann sofort kaufen alte hat 1700
euro geboten von teva habe schon 112
gebot ich jetzt gleich noch besuch und
dann müsste es eigentlich passiert ein
bisschen also die kaufen haben wir 2500
euro aber ich so kaufte er sich doch
nicht direkt ist ab sofort kommen 2000
euro vielleicht ist er korrekt und denkt
sich oder denken die sicher kommen dass
wir guten zweck sucht warum nicht also
ich muss sagen wir legen jetzt 5210 euro
hier sind jetzt schon so viele gebote
die hier stehen
irgendwie denke ich mir das ist ja das
ist bisschen feldes oder irgendwie frage
ich mich jetzt gerade 26 nachrichten
habe ich schon bekommen wäre cool finde
meine box out obst ich würde das geld
auch spenden okay klar müsse wie bei 600
euro jobs auf iphones und playstation
fünf und so weiter sehr vertrauenswürdig
also irgendwie weiß ich nicht was da
passiert viel zu kommen irgendwann
standen wir schon bei 1600 1700 euro und
ich dachte mir warum kauft diese person
weil man konnte meine box für 2000 euro
auch selber kaufen also einfach sofort
kaufen und dann wirst deinen dingen
gewesen so wobei ich ehrlicherweise auch
sagen muss dass 2000 euro dafür schon
relativ viel
gewesen wären also da ist auf jeden fall
eine menge warenwert drin auf 2000 euro
sind weiß ich nicht glauben aber er
hätte ja passieren könnte ich meinen das
wäre ja alles für den guten zweck
gewesen dann ging es weiter und weiter
und 10.000 euro und 15.000 euro
wir haben so viele leute geschrieben
alter deine box ist bei 20.000 euro
alter der box ist bei 30.000 euro 250
tausend euro bei 130000 euro
ich glaube das letzte gebot ich kann es
dir gern ein band war irgendwie 133 1250
euro
meinig und da dachte ich soll was ist
jetzt los als wenn jemand wirklich mir
diese 133000 euro da bezahlt das fand
ich dann schon sehr komisch ich habe
allerdings nichts unternommen ich hab
das einfach drin gelassen erst mal
einbringen lassen das angebot war ja
auch nur für drei tage gültig ich habe
allerdings auch am ersten tag sondern
nachricht von ebay bekommen kann ich
euch auch super gerne hier mal ein
werden da stand wir müssen leider ihr
angebot löschen weil es gegen die
richtlinien verstößt ich habe glaube ich
noch genauer beschreiben müssen was in
der box drin ist weil man halt nicht so
überraschungspakete über ebay
versteigern darf allerdings ist nichts
passiert also die haben es nicht
gelöscht keine ahnung was dann mit der
mail oder warum ich diese mail bekommen
hat und dann habe ich glücklicherweise
ein paar aufmerksame zuschauer darauf
hingewiesen dass wahrscheinlich diese
133000 euro die da halt geboten wurden
von irgendwelchen ich muss es an der
stelle leider sagen unter menschen das
geht nicht in meinem kopf rein wie man
solche aktion derart zerstören kann also
das waren einfach so genannte spaß
bieter wohl die einfach irgendwie geld
darauf bieten und ich dachte immer man
muss das dann auch wirklich bezahlen
wenn man es bietet man wird dann
irgendwie von ebay dazu gezwungen aber
von wem kann man schon 130.000 euro dann
verlangen und das beste wäre gewesen ich
habe ja meine kreditkarte da hinterlegt
und man muss glaube ich zehn prozent
gebühren an ebay abdrücken das wären
dann einfach dann vielleicht einfach
13.000 euro von meiner kreditkarte
runter gegangen hätte ich dieses angebot
nicht vor diesen drei tagen gelöscht und
das wird theoretisch glaube ich gehen
dass das abgebucht wird das heißt ich
werde es einfach um 13.000 euro ärmer
nur wegen irgendwelchen idioten die eine
spendenaktion so zerstören
zum glück konnte ich dann fünf stunden
vor ablauf selber noch löschen und dann
ist das auch verfallen also mir wurden
nicht abgezogen oder so das war sehr gut
aber ich habe jetzt halt lange hin und
her überlegt was mache ich jetzt weil
wir haben jetzt zwar schon einiges an
geld damit gewonnen sei es jetzt mit dem
wii
an sich kann ich euch super gerne hier
mal ein werden oder auch mit dem paypal
spenden ich hab nämlich gesagt wir
können super gerne einfach an die
organisation direkt spenden oder mir das
eigentlich per paypal schicken dann
deutlich dass weiter ich meine da
müssten auch ist jetzt nicht mega viel
aber auf jeden fall schon mal anfangen
etwas über 200 euro von euch zusammen
gekommen sein kann ich euch auch hier
gerne einbinden aber ich habe gedacht
die meisten erlöse kommen safe von der
ebay auktion konnte ich jetzt leider
noch gar kein geld mit einnehmen wir
machen das jetzt folgendermaßen die idee
kommt auch von einer zuschauerin glaube
ich schöne grüße an dicht falls du das
siehst und zwar die gesagt alex nimmt
doch einfach von jeder person irgendwie
zwei euro oder so und die nehmen dann
automatisch an einer verlosung wieder
teil und ich finde die idee eigentlich
ganz gut weil ich meinen zwei euro
schaden jetzt niemanden groß denke ich
mal ihr habt eine kleine chance diese
mystery box zu gewinnen und selbst wenn
ihr sie nicht gewinnen könnt ihr immer
noch sagen okay die zwei euro waren für
den guten zweck und das schadet ja
niemand da kann man sich doch eigentlich
auch nur darüber freuen deswegen die box
steht da ich kann sie eigentlich noch
mal kurz holen hier haben wir das paket
ist wirklich voll bis obenhin komplett
mit technik eigentlich also die hat
wirklich einen guten wert ich würde mich
sehr freuen wenn einfach jeder von euch
mitmachen oder so viele wie möglich
einfach zwei euro als teilnahmegebühr
damit man weiß okay die person meines
ernst an meinen paypal schicken alex wie
mail at web.de wenn ihr noch jünger
seite oder ihr kein paypal konto hat
dann tragt eure eltern oder meinetwegen
irgendwie freunden kannst du zwei euro
dahin schicken ich geb dir dann zwei
euro in bar
das kann man ja auch so lösen und dann
machen hoffentlich ganz viele mit und
ich suche dann irgendwann zufällig eine
person aus der schreibe ich dann eine
e-mail weil man sieht bei paypal ja auch
direkte mal die e mail und den krieg
dann die box von mir und so werden wir
hoffentlich noch viele spenden sammeln
das heißt unterm strich habe ich dir
jetzt leider nicht für 133 1250 euro
verkauft weil irgendwelche falls passten
da mir ein strich durch die rechnung
gemacht haben aber vielleicht kann man
so auf diesem weg ja noch mehr geld
damit erzielen und dann dorthin spenden
und ja ich freue mich ich hoffe ihr
feiert das auf und ja das war es
eigentlich auch schon mit dem heutigen
video weil es nichts krass ist aber das
lag mir einfach nur auf dem herzen das
jetzt durchzuziehen und dann möglichst
viel geld zu sammeln und wir sehen uns
dann hier denke ich übermorgen mit einem
coolen video wieder dank fürs zuschauen
abonniert super gern main kanal haut
rein leute